I'm going to talk about DNA sequencing
so first what is DNA sequencing DNA
sequencing consists of several steps
first step is typically a chemical step
where you take some intact DNA like
blood samples put it into a machine and
then tears it apart into smaller
fragments and prints out files that have
these fragments to give you a bit an
idea of the dimensions and intact human
DNA consists of three billion base pairs
each base pairs is one of the letters G
a B or C and the fragments that come out
of these machines are typically about
150 base pairs this is then typically
followed by a software pipeline and
there's many kinds of different
pipelines that you may want to express
over these fragments but the typical one
is variant calling that is quite often
used so variant calling first
does a process called mapping where
tries to puzzle together the original
DNA sequence out of these fragments and
then the second step after some sorting
and some additional steps the second
phase is then of called variant calling
where you try to figure out which parts
of the DNA are different from that of a
normal DMA these software pipelines have
a lot of use cases in clinical
Diagnostics or in R&D departments of
Hamas which the pharmaceutical companies
for example and they tend to take a lot
of time we're talking about days of
processing time sometimes what we've
done a couple of years ago is we
developed a tool called elltrev together
with Young's and pharmaceuticals and
Intel Corporation which is a
high-performance tool for preparing such
files for variant calling it's a
multi-threaded application where we
reorganized the software architecture so
it can completely run run in DRAM and
take advantage of parallelism and this
allows us to write certain parts of the
pipeline up to ten times faster than
standard tools it's open source we have
a paper about this where we describe the
software architecture and so on the
original implementation of this was in
common lisp common lists has a couple of
great advantages it's good for
prototyping it's good for moving
prototypes to production however there
were also a couple of problem
especially with memory management since
these files are quite large tens to
hundreds of gigabytes in uncompressed
form this puts a lot of stress on the
garbage collector when you put all of
this in RAM the garbage collectors in
common this tend to be stop the world
garbage collectors which stop all the
threats which is bad for parallelism so
when you look at the modern landscape of
memory management there's reference
counting and concurrent garbage
collection and these are the only mature
implementations thereof that we were
aware of and that we were able to use
rust doesn't count and Objective C
doesn't count for various reasons so
here are the results
we used an input data set which is a
whole exome data set 13 gigabytes
compressed data we ran on to socket
machine with 22 cores each and this is
the result so for C++ with those tools
we got 13 minutes 38 seconds at 227
gigabytes of RAM with Java it looks
worse so there's different garbage
collection options for Java but if it's
faster it uses a ridiculous amount of
memory which can't be used if it's lower
even then it uses a large amount of
memory so that doesn't really count and
we'd go with the default setting in 1.7
we got 10 minutes 20 seconds at an
amount of ram that's very close to the
lowest so we were very happy with that
and that's why we moved to our elltrev
tool to go publish this as open source
one month ago it was easiest to
implement the whole thing in Java
because of the parallel streams
framework but mainly we parted this also
to go and also of the source this so you
can download this and be happy with this
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]